uh so I can see that few more
participants have joined so those who
have just joined it would be great if
you could introduce yourself in the chat
box with your educational background and
research interest and we'll be starting
with the webinar in few moments
hello uzma thank you for introducing
yourself and we are glad to have you
back
uh I'm curious to know do you have any
research interests if so please mention
that as well in the chat box
all right so hello everyone a very warm
greeting to one and all my name is
Krishna Kumar and I would like to
welcome you all for today's webinar on
omixlogic Research fellowship program we
we all know that publishing a research
paper is an important step in your
career whether you choose to pursue an
academic or industry field writing and
Publishing a research paper however is
not an easy job it needs time
appropriate training and Mentor guidance
that is why we have designed the omics
logic research fellowship program to
help young researchers and students from
diverse range of backgrounds to take
advantage of the bioinformatic resources
for analysis of complex life science
data
the fellowship program will offer a
combination of online resources and
mental guidance to prepare you and help
you complete a balanced marriage project
more details about the challenges faced
by students in accessing bioinformatic
resources job opportunities registration
costs Etc will be discussed during the
webinar and we are also joined by one of
our former research fellow China dingra
to share her journey from being a
beginner in mathematics to how she is
preparing for publishing her project
so before we begin with today's webinar
let me also take a brief moment to
introduce you to the team behind the
program we are a us-based bioinformatics
company who's working with multiple
academic and Commercial collaborators to
develop easy to use analytical tools and
our mission is to make bioinformatics
more accessible
as a part of the program students will
have access to the omics logic training
that has been completed by over 24 000
participants from 187 countries in over
300 workshops and due to this fast
growth our team is working with local
and Regional coordinators that are
helping refine local program Logistics
and adapting them to the needs of
students and researchers around the
world and this training has been
completed by participants in six
different specialization tracks that
includes oncology infectious diseases
Precision medicine Neuroscience data
science for biomedical data and
comprehensive training on omic's data
analysis
students will also have access to omic
strategic resources but how does it help
Advance bioinformatics teaching
omixiologic is a portal for practical
and theoretical learning of
bioinformatics it takes a combination of
training modules data analysis tools
curated project data sets and
interactive sessions with mentors to
give the student a clear path of the
gloom's taxonomy pyramid and no matter
what the user's initial experience with
bioinformatics is omic's logic is a
useful tool for gaining a baseline
knowledge of the theory behind
bioinformatics analysis of large data
sets and introduction to basic coding
languages like R and python or even
beginning a data analysis project
this also comes with an access to the
omic strategy courses which includes
courses on bioinformatics Precision
medicine multi-ourmets including
genomics transcriptomics epigenomics
metagenomics data science that includes
bioinformatics using R and python as
well as cheminformatics and example
projects of different fields which you
could learn from and replicate for your
research work
users will be given directions to access
the T bioinfo platform for bioinformatic
processing and Analysis of data and the
platform includes demo pipelines as well
as data management and Analysis Cloud
infrastructure to run the bioinformatic
pipelines and different stages of
analysis are performed in different
sections on this multionics platform
to view the various courses example
projects and student projects you need
to first sign up on the omics logic loan
portal before that let me walk you
through a brief demo on what a completed
profile on the portal looks like
so once you sign up on the portal these
are the features that you need to update
on your account that is a complete
profile will have a profile image full
name with appropriate capitalization
link to your social media handles this
could be your Facebook LinkedIn
Instagram or ID Twitter a brief BioWare
about yourself that will consist of your
educational background and research
interest and the mentors can view your
progress under the activity Tab and the
courses you're currently completing will
appear under the courses Tab and finally
after the completion of your course the
certificates will appear under the
certificates tab
so now you might be wondering what comes
after completing the courses and example
projects as a part of your research
fellowship program the answer is
possibilities are endless for instance
you could go on to perform a research
project like as the bhagava a
bioinformatic graduate from Amity
University Rajasthan who completed a
research project in the field of
oncology she uploaded a project on the
learn portal where an International
Community of students peers and
bioinformatics experts can watch her
presentation recording read through her
research project like share and comment
their feedback under the comment session
so in the chat box I'm pasting the link
to her project
so that the participants can take a look
and another interesting student project
outcome can be you see in case of
Delilah taken a molecular biology and
genetics graduate from University of
turkey who completed a project in the
field of astrobiology which she went on
to present at the psyomix club session a
session where an International Learning
Community of biomatic enthusiasts come
together to share their work debate on
important topics and share their queries
to stay up to date with latest
advancements in the field so here's the
link to the session
that you can take a look at
and for in addition to this she also
went on to publish her project as a
preprint on bioarchive that she can
share with her peers mentors and
potential employers for future
connections and you can take a look at
her free print here
father you also have the opportunity to
participate in post-presentation
competition as a part of omics research
Symposium like Dr Uma yadav who worked
on machine learning project for which
she won best technical research project
as less exciting cash prizes and this
Symposium is an international research
Symposium that brings together experts
from around the globe to talk about
important topics the student projects
are not just limited to graduates and
doctorates for instance Andre more
thanosa a high school student at Mexico
presented his Neuroscience project at
the Regent one international science and
engineering fair for which he won the
potamkin prize and the fourth award in
the biomedical and Health Sciences
category you can learn more about his
work in this link that I'm providing in
the chat box
so now to view the various courses
example projects and student projects
let us Begin by signing up on The omics
Logical important let me share the link
in the chat box
so here's the link for signing up on the
portal
so please click on the link and I'll
walk you through the process on how you
can sign up so for those participants
who have not signed up on the portal yet
please click on the create an account
option that you're seeing here and here
you will be asked to enter your name
email ID and password you can create an
account using any of this option or you
also have the option to login using any
of your social media handles that could
be Google Facebook Apple account GitHub
account or even Twitter and with that I
will pause for a couple of seconds so
that the participants can sign up on the
portal and if you're facing any queries
on how you can sign up please share them
in the chat and I'll help you
so I'm waiting for the responses in the
chat once you have signed up please put
a yes in the chat box and for those
participants who have already signed up
please put a done in the chat box so
that I know I can proceed
so I'm waiting for the 40 plus
participants to share there all right
here we have said it's done
all right I'm getting couple of done so
I'm going to login now since I already
have an account on the total so once you
sign in you'll be able to view the
various courses and example projects and
here uh in the tab that's asked looking
for a specific course you can enter the
keyword that you're looking for so let's
say you're interested in machine
learning
so you can simply enter the keyword that
you're interested in and it will show
all the courses and example projects
that you are interested
and now coming to the part where uh you
need to update your account for that you
can click on the tab that says welcome
back with your email ID and here you
will see a button that says profile when
you click on this you will be asked to
enter your profile image and your bio
and the bio will consist of your
educational background and research
interests and make sure that when you
enter your name it has to be in proper
capitalization as well as link your
social media handles for instance in my
case I have updated my LinkedIn account
and my all kind and this is the tab
section where under the activity tab the
community manager and the mentor of your
program will be able to track your
learning progress and once you start
taking any of the courses the courses
will appear under the core system and if
you upload any research project by
guzzul bhargava it will be displayed
under the project stack and when you
enroll for the program for instance a
research fellowship program it will
appear under the program style and
finally when you complete the courses
and required assignments the
certificates will appear under the
certificates tab so to that I'll pause
for a couple of moments to share okay
race assassin finding sign up difficult
at my end
um so if any of the team members could
like look into it
uh can you tell me like what is the
issue that you are facing
you could also unmute yourself and let
me know what is the
trouble that you're facing while signing
up
okay thank you I've been able to stop it
you know okay it wasn't bringing out the
page for me to go through login before
so I just blank
is it showing blank
yes it was showing blank would you see
could you please take a look into it or
how we can help her
uh yesterday maybe up this webinar I
will mail an application
okay sure thank you so much so we'll
look into it please don't worry and with
that if the participants uh have any
other queries please let me know and
I'll help you navigate through the
portal otherwise now I'd like to invite
China dingra she completed her Masters
in biotechnology from Amity University
Noida and she joined for research
fellowship program as a complete
beginner in bioinismatics and as a part
of a plan to pursue PhD program she is
now planning to re-enroll for the
program and complete a new project to
get it published and with that brief
introduction now I'd like to pass on the
stage to China so the stage is all
leaders
let me try it
okay are you able to unmute yourself now
could you please try speaking now I'm
trying to unmute you
it looks like we are not able to uh hear
you
although your audio scenes
um unmute
could you please try joining from your
yes uh can you speak
hello yes
uh you're Audible
um
share my presentation
uh okay sure give me a moment
um
there you go
so yes you can start with your
presentation
so
uh hello everyone my name is
my experience on Research Fellowship
training provided by Pine biotech next
slide
so let me introduce myself I am China
dhingra postgraduate in biotechnology I
have completed my Bachelor's of honors
and biotechnology and Masters of Science
and biotechnology from Amity University
Noida I have done my research fellowship
at fine biotech a few months back under
the guidance of Dr raghav so I was
always interested in biomedical I am I I
am always interested in biomedical
science bioinformatics and cancer
biology
the next slide
I started my I started my training by
going through various courses available
at omic's logic website I started I
started with introduction to
bioinformatics where I learned about Big
Data big data bioinformatics and its
importance in healthcare and research
then I started with transcriptomics this
was a major this was the main course
that helped me to perform my project
here I learned about how to perform RNA
sequence data analysis how to run
pipeline rn2tband for server and to how
to perform statistical analysis of
different based genes and also how I
learned about how to perform
t-test then I went for our coding course
one here I learned about analysis of
biological data using R and how to
analyze genomic sequence then I went for
R coding course to this course involved
Advanced Training uh like machine
learning and statistical analysis so
basically these courses helped me to
help me how to design my research
project these are only some of the
project where there are many other
available on omic logic website next
slide
after going through these courses I
started with my project work so my
project and title is to identify novel
biomarkers for thyroid cancer using
multi-ohomics data analysis my project
involves three major steps that is
differential expression analysis
biological interpretation and to submit
data so let me give you a brief
introduction about how I perform my
project
if I downloaded I downloaded the data
set four data sets from the Geo database
then with the help of different
bioinformatics tools and analyze and
interpret it the for all the four data
sets this data sets were available in
the form of microarray data so it's
normally it's normalized so I didn't
perform any quantile normalization I
introduced them into Excel to find the
uh to find differentially expressed
genes so to find a regulated genes I
perform t-test
and I could identify a tribulated
differentially expressed genes for all
the all the four data assets so using uh
so I matched after this I matched the
probe IDs with their corresponding Gene
symbols uh this side this I performed
using R Studio
ah using left join function in our
studio also I perform uh also I prepared
heat maps for all the differentially
expressed genes for all the four data
sets after uh this I also performed
principal component analysis for all the
four data set using the raw data so this
principle a PC analysis was performed
using T by info server and next slide
these are some of the snaps from my
research work so scat uh
PCA analysis was performed using t-band
for server and I performed Scatter Plots
using Excel
and uh to find number of intersection of
differentially expressed Gene I have
performed I prepared an upset plot using
R studio so I could identify 13 genes
among these 13 genes four genes were
related to cancer that can be proper
Target for treatment options so I
analyze this uh
13 genes using David to study their Gene
Ornithology functional annotation and
path phase
also I use string database to find
protein protein and traction between the
genes also I perform disease free
analysis or all disease free survival
analysis for all the 13 genes also are
performed box plots and this way I could
identify four genes that for that
are implicated in cancer that can be
probable Target for treatment options
next slide
so after I was done with my project I
um I introduced um I uh my I my first
poster presentation at Pine biotech
research Symposium this was my first
poster presentation this was after I
completed my three months research
Fellowship training
uh next slide
so this is how I did my research
Fellowship training first I uh first I
went through some courses available at
their uh available at omix Lodge's
website then I started with my project
thank you
thank you so much so I do have a like a
few queries for you so did you
um find any courses or example projects
uh that you really liked and that helped
you come up with a idea for uh
completing your research project
yeah I I really like our coding like uh
and TCG liver cancer uh data analysis
project that is available on the portal
all right and uh do we have any
um uh advice for someone who is new to
this program and who's planning to
enroll for it so along the way was there
any kind of mistakes that you made and
that you would like to share with us so
that if you don't also end up making the
same mistake
uh for me at uh in the starting it was
like it everything was new but it was
Advanced like it was I knew it was worth
it so I I took the guidance of Dr raghav
and other mentors that were available so
I would recommend that if you face any
problem just ask them also you there are
everything available on the courses but
still if you are performing any
individual project you can uh you can
ask any the mentors that are available
from the mentors that are available
all right and uh one final query is uh
would you like to recommend this program
to other students who might be uh
confused whether they should enroll or
not
yes I would because they uh it provides
Hands-On training on bioinformatics
research but you can perform your any
research project uh that uh
independently
yes
all right then thank you so much you
know that was really great presentation
and thank you for sharing your uh advice
for other participants uh and now I'd
like to pass on the stage to Dr Mohit
mazumdar uh who will be speaking about
what are the various challenges that
students face in the uh education system
presently and what are some of the job
opportunities that they can take a look
at so over to you sir
thank you srigari for the introduction
and also thank you so much China for
this wonderful presentation
um I would like to share my screen but
also thank you all of those who have
joined today's session and are
interested in learning more about the
project so if it is not already shared
I'd request from the team that those who
are here to share the link for the
project that Sheena has worked on on the
omix logic and people who are interested
to learn more about our project and the
data set and the entire methodology that
is also published on omix logical learn
uh so can you confirm uh is it is my
screen visible
yes sir it was
all right thank you so much
um again a very good very warm uh
evening and morning and afternoon uh to
all of you uh joining from different uh
geographical locations uh I'm really
happy to meet you all and uh we are
really excited to talk about some of the
new updates some of the things that we
are doing and which in return helping a
lot of students as well as faculty and
research institutions so uh to start
with I'd like to talk a little bit about
my own Journey so that you can
understand how it has been and learn
from a first-hand experience so I have
done my masters in bioinformatics and my
PhD in computational biology uh working
in a research lab and trying to work and
address some of the pressing challenges
that the lab understands and gets
funding for and to be able to help the
team uh come up with research solutions
by using data by using bioinformatics by
using algorithms by using research as a
tool so that has been a great experience
in my PhD and there were a lot of
Publications coming out of it and a lot
of recognition that I got through that
program however I think that after going
through that entire program and also
like the the way things have changed now
it's kind of obvious that many of the
things that we used to do we can do this
quickly and we can do this in in a more
meaningful Manner and so that we can
reach better outcomes bigger outcomes
and one of the challenges in science in
general and especially in the space of
biology and biomedical research is the
limitations in Innovation is the
limitations in finding solutions to
healthcare challenges that you that you
have seen that how we have suffered in
this covet pandemic and how we are still
trying to understand uh and trying to
solve many answered challenges such as
the neurodegenerative diseases such as
cancer such as other infectious disease
challenges so there is a lot of
opportunity because at the same time
when we are thinking about solving these
challenges then we are also thinking
about how who all are thinking about it
and also governments and other
organizations funding organizations are
thinking about it and they're putting
their effort to solve these problems so
what is required from us is to be able
to deal with such problem become or be
that capacity to help such projects to
get such opportunities in research
institutions to get job opportunities in
bigger companies with a good profile and
also to think about startup
opportunities all of those things are
now doable and it's a huge huge change
that has happened over the last few
years and uh it's kind of very important
to know know this and be aware of this
so that's the reason I'm discussing all
of this and in my experience I completed
my PhD
I worked with several of the researchers
and scientists around the globe to work
on several different problems and I
realized that we are kind of getting
close and close to finding uh answers
that are more relevant to our to our
health so using all of that information
and using a structured way I think we
can find these Solutions much quicker
and also we can use these Solutions as
an opportunity to get good jobs get good
internships or get good exposures for
higher education for other types of
opportunities such as the finding and
starting a startup get funding so all of
this this is very exciting at this point
of time because of this Innovation that
is happening in the space of biomedical
data science bioinformatics and all of
that so that's what we are also doing
and I hope that many of you are also
excited about the innovations that this
field is bringing in the in in for human
health and well-being
so with that
I have a few things that I wanted to
show some of the developments that we've
been working on and how all of this is
making sense in finding solutions to
those unsolved challenges as well as
finding you know well-being amongst us
like finding well-being is like having a
good life having a good job and all of
that getting the right kind of
opportunity so how all of this is
working for us and what kind of models
we have prepared and what kind of
opportunities that are there is
something that I wanted to cover in this
session and I hope that we will be able
to discuss a little bit more about all
of this and feel free to write in the
chat uh because uh I'll be able to uh
interact with you and answer some of the
questions that you might have
all right so my experience in my
experience as I was telling you I did my
PhD and then I was uh I started working
for an industry I I from my PhD from my
academic experience I I transferred that
experience for an industrial job
opportunity and I was working with a
bioinformatics company to provide
solutions for big Pharma now big Pharma
and small Pharma and other biotech
companies they do use a lot of
bioinformatics and they do use a lot of
data to to derive these and to solve
these problems or come up with you know
drug Discovery Diagnostics and all of
the things that are done in the
healthcare sector in in today's world so
in this modern 21st century what we have
been seeing is a volume of data like
really really big big volumes of data
and something that we have learned also
from the previous presentation that
where um Gina was using multiomics data
which is like different types of homics
data which in itself is a large volume
of data in terms of the size but also to
find those information which are
relevant for what we are finding in to
finding solutions to healthcare problems
so after my PhD I joined industry and
our objective was to find those
solutions for big data for big Pharma
companies who who would want to
Outsource some of this work uh to have
to get a faster result get uh uh get a
result that they would like to go
forward for clinical trials and such
studies so that was my experience
working with big Pharma and then I
joined uh joined Pine biotech where I
could understand now that what has
happened what is happening in the
industry what are the gaps in the
Academia and how I we can help students
and and all this uh researchers who are
really struggling to find answers to the
research questions that that data can
find data can help in so there's this is
the information that we are not so used
to you know taking into consideration
because it's spread out and it's also
not structured and that's what we have
done in this research Fellowship in this
omix logic training and that's what we
I'm going to show you in the next uh few
a few slides that I've prepared for
today's session
so
um first thing first uh I would wanted
to tell you all about some of the
upcoming updates and also some of the
research partners because what we are
trying to do is to build build a
research Community it's not to be done
alone so we have a lot of research
Partners we have a lot of academic
Partners all around the globe who are
helping in the same way that to find and
solve problems uh help students to
understand the problems and also use the
the research capacity and also use the
student capacity and also the faculty
ideas to be to incorporate and solve
these biomedical challenges solve these
Healthcare issues that the mankind is
facing so for this we have collaborators
uh from all around the globe as well as
top research institutes which are who
are helping us with research projects
who are helping us also to bring
opportunities for students so this
community is not just for learning this
Community is also for job opportunities
this community is also for internships
this community is also for higher
education and recommendation and all of
the things that a student a researcher
would need in his entire uh Journey so
uh not just uh that but also how
industry is utilizing all of this so we
have a lot of industrial Partners who
are helping us with sessions helping
Mentor students helping us by recruiting
hiring students for internships for
full-time job opportunities
and also for projects which are more
relevant which we are working on uh
collaboratively so all of those are
opportunities that I'm going to tell you
about and tell you also the pathway to
get there
um to find the gaps and fill those gaps
so yeah obviously we all of us has have
some gaps which could be filled up that
would help us translate our you know
thoughts into a better way to get the
right opportunity so how do we do that
what is the things that we require to
get place to get placed to get the
opportunity and also to work on
something that really excites us because
this bioinformatics and this data
science and this big data has enabled a
lot of researchers a lot of students to
be able to work on a project that that
really is close to them because it could
be a family problem it could be
something that we are seeing as a
problem in our local
areas so we we are now capable of
working on those problems and finding
Solutions and there are also business
models which helps us generate money to
cover all of that so yeah that is all of
this is possible and some of this is uh
what we are doing and bring such
opportunities for students for
researchers for faculty for companies so
um also for Academia as many students
join us we have academic Partners where
we are running these programs and if any
of you are from our uh our collaborator
we have obviously a special program uh
designed for a collaborating
universities uh that helps students to
take these in with scholarships and
other options so please let us know
about if you're from our from a
collaborate University when you reach
out for a specific training when you
reach out for a specific uh course or
specific need or help
now um connecting all of this there are
few Industries who are utilizing this
data the industry who is generating this
data is the next Generation sequencing
industry and we have uh our academic and
our industry Partners both working in
collaborative projects as well as
working on specific projects and courses
and mentorship so uh the industry
partnership is something that health is
helping a lot of students and helping a
lot of research think about the
translational research so um with that
we also have uh Partners who are from
Pharma industry and where we are working
on specific problems related to Pharma
specific problems which are related to
drug Discovery and also mentors and uh
and and Founders and co-founders who are
in this space helping get the right kind
of opportunity once the training is
complete once the internship is complete
and once you prove that you have the
skill sets to be able to get integrated
into the industry
so with Pharma Healthcare and again like
Ai and artificial intelligence working
on specific healthcare related projects
so we have Partnerships with such
companies who are helping us work on Big
Data projects generate or build Next
Generation see next-gen solutions for
healthcare and life science based on the
need based on specific geographies based
on uh the the
the investment that is available so that
is a very important component also to
understand where are the main problems
are and how the bigger organizations are
tackling these problems where there are
investments where there are and when
there are investments there are
opportunities
now um with our uh University model that
we have uh we are working with several
of our University partners and I was
just wanted to give you a quick update
that what we are doing with our
University partner is a hybrid model so
we are traveling and we are meeting with
students course and going through
workshops together so recently we went
to a family to Jaipur and met with a lot
of students and helped them with their
projects uh help them with some of the
guidance that are required for them to
start this and we also recently
collaborated with IIT jodhpur and we are
working with them to develop a program
that would be really helpful for a large
number of audiences where they could be
able to do NGS experiments with the help
of life science companies such as primas
and data analysis uh with the help of
with the help of the trainers that are
available in IIT and also the IIT
infrastructure and also the guidance of
great mentors like such as Professor
mythology who has been one of the
leaders in India in genomics so really
happy with all of these collaborations
and this entire Community because this
community you can also be a part of by
joining one of our programs such as the
research fellowship program which we are
discussing today and a collaborate and
work on several opportunities and
projects with industry as well as
Academia so that's the whole idea and
similarly we went to Noida and we met
with a lot of students and faculty and
head and of the institutions where we
discussed what are the challenges that
are there in such training and we kind
of are addressing some of these
challenges by telling you about some of
these opportunities that are available
so um this is the entire picture like
from universities from industry from uh
from healthcare industry from NGS
industry from different types of Pharma
industry we are connecting all of this
community to bring you the best kind of
job opportunities to bring you the best
kind of training opportunities and also
to bringing you the best kind of career
guidance that is something would go a
long way and help us get to some of the
objectives that we think of
accomplishing as a company which is to
help the healthcare sector to be a part
important part of this Healthcare sector
and help in provide providing our
analysis so some of the analysis that we
are going to go through in such in such
such a training is you know to
understand where this data is like we
have been discussing about uh different
types of you know outcomes what people
have done but from a data perspective we
go through some of these Technologies
and it could be simplified and that's
what we have done we have simplified all
of this into different coursework that
Shri gauri was just showing you into
different projects that are structured
in a training based on the interest that
you have so this is uh What uh what is
like put put up together we have
learning models where if you're a
beginner you can start from a beginner
level if you're intermediate you can
directly go to the intermediate level
and if you have already done the
beginner coursework you can start
working on the advanced coursework and
then there are specializations where you
can work on there are different types of
data types that you can work on and also
specific type of research specialization
and research projects so this is entire
omics logic mix logic training that
gives you like connections experience
guidance validations skills and
recognition so all of this is uh done
through a pathway that we have prepared
that we have created for you for those
who are joining us that includes the
basic training or anyone who joins we
think that some basic training would
help them progress really fast through
this process because earlier and in a
PhD it takes five years to complete a
research and what we are doing uh what
China did was in three months she could
do work on such a good project and if if
you work a little bit more you end up
publishing such project you end up
writing a grant about that project so
there are endless opportunity you apply
for job opportunities based on that
project and I'll come to those job
opportunities that are available uh that
are really available at this time so so
this is the pipeline you go if you're in
basic stage we have the we have it
covered if you're an advanced training
stage that is also something that we can
help you with which is to go through Big
Data analysis learn about coding apply
machine learning deep learning and then
what kind of specialization is something
that really is exciting because we do
want to do like get into a good job but
in the end
um the job satisfaction is not just
about the money it's also about what we
want to achieve in that job uh how we
are happy and satisfied by after doing
that job so this is where the
specialization I think plays a key role
and uh if you are really interested in
some of the specializations that are
like relevant to on to your local area
that are relevant to your uh country
that are really relevant to your family
there is an opportunity because there is
a lot of data which is available and
that's what we have shown that if you
work on that data if you work through a
structured program if you get the good
good if you get a good Mentor behind all
of this and we have created all of that
by utilizing the T by info platform that
you have seen the omish logic learn and
also a group of mentors that have been
discussing you all about so the T by
info platform is actually something that
really helps in all of this process
because many of the beginner level
students uh it's difficult to understand
the complexity so the T by info platform
actually simplifies all of this it
covers all the homeless data it combines
heterogeneous data and has a very simple
into YouTube interface to create complex
analysis pipelines so all of this is
something to understand the logic of
analysis so you do have an AI guided
platform that enables us to do all this
big data analysis all this machine
learning analysis with an ease with very
very
um easy weight easy process to go
through which is uh all covered in the
coursework where you learn about all of
this in a stepwise manner so you learn
from the coursework you do your practice
here and you work on your project but
this is where you learn about the basic
concepts this is where you practice on
uh working on projects that are already
been done and example projects then you
start working on your own projects so
these are some of the pathways from
where you can you know progress from one
step to another so all of this pathway
we have resources we have mentors we
have material and we have practical
sessions and guidance to go through and
Achieve that so this is really a a great
place to be able to do some of these
analysis and get expertise and develop
those expertise in a step by or a stage
wise manner which makes more sense when
you progress from a simple to more
complex to a more and more complex
problem
uh and one of the best thing is that all
of this is available online so a big
data platform where you can crunch
gigabytes 10 terabytes of data and that
you can do at an ease like setting from
anywhere isn't that great so the
opportunity is there for all of you to
think about this start thinking about
and uh to do that if you're a beginner
we have all the introductory coursework
we have example data sets that gives us
a lot of idea that what we can do if you
are not if you're not thinking about an
idea if you don't have an idea that's
perfectly all right because we as we
learn as we read we get to know about
many things and that's how we generate
and get those get to those ideas and
that's the entire pathway so basic
training intermediate training helps you
develop that idea helps you think about
newer ideas and in the project research
the the research work that you're doing
afterwards so in a one month training
one month could be about the basic
training and other man could be
understanding the research problem and
the third month is where you start
working on your own project so we have
three months and six month models and
also like longer models that we will be
discussing in a while
but to tell you a little bit about the
opportunities as I was telling you about
the Tiba info platform we have the learn
oh mixed logic platform where you learn
about the basic coursework where you
cover the intermediate coursework and
where you also do the advanced
coursework or you do a specialization
project or an independent project after
learning about a specific specialization
so you don't have to do all of those
things but you can choose if you want to
work on a Precision medicine project if
you are into agriculture you can choose
to work on agriculture so there are a
lot of variety from infectious diseases
if you have think about any type of
diseases and if if there is a data
available then there is a possibility
that there is something Noble that we
can find from that so that's about the
program but how it connects how all of
this is connected with the job
opportunities so on our portal uh and
I'll request to just be to share the
link uh we have been posting about the
job opportunities so uh if you look at
these job opportunities you would think
that uh
what are the different things these
companies are asking for what are the
different things that these
organizations are looking into so
academic job opportunities industrial
job opportunities internships and then
career building opportunities so
experience building opportunities so
there are different types of
opportunities we are thinking about
which are available so what kind of
opportunity are you are you looking for
because if you are a beginner you would
like to do an internship you would know
how you would want to know how the
system works and then you're like easily
integrated into a system internships are
a great way to get integrated in a
bigger organizations who would want to
test so similarly this internship
opportunities and all of these job
opportunities what is required and how
to get those this is a really important
question so I have I have a thing to to
maybe
uh discuss and tell all of you today
which I wanted to is that many of these
job opportunities you will find if
you're a student and if you're an early
researcher you'll find that they have a
specific requirement over the number of
years number of ex years of experience
and all of that like which tells which
kind of gives the company an assurance
that you have learned enough you have
worked enough you have experienced
enough to tackled different types of
problem and work in an industry setting
so those are diff those are really uh
very important things for an industry to
consider which we are not thinking about
it when we are applying for the industry
so those are the things that we have to
consider and that's where we have been
able to help students with industry
mentorship like what how to translate
from Academia to Industry uh when we are
doing this research Fellowship programs
many of our students are going to
Industry and joining the industry and
through this internal training that we
are being able to provide how to
translate it into industry with the
skill sets that you have and what kind
of skill sets the industry is looking
for so one of the examples and one of
the challenges that I just told you
about is that number of years of
experience so one of the best thing one
could do which we were not able to do is
to start really early if you're an
undergraduate this is the time for you
to start gaining this experience by
working on Project working on different
types of challenges and the
opportunities with omics logic and with
other organizations as well but here
what we are trying to do is to give you
a basic from beginner level to a very
strong Foundation into the entire you
know this entire field where everything
is possible right now because of the
depth of the data and the technological
advancements so these are some of the
things that I wanted to tell you I
wanted to encourage all of you to start
thinking about it connect what are the
opportunities use the portal learn from
us and get help uh whenever you are are
needed of help so to end this uh all of
this we discussed about job
opportunities which are relevant to the
skill sets now there are also startup
opportunities so we we uh either we want
to start a join a company or do we want
to start a company uh do we have that do
we have that skill sets so we uh kind of
are helping those students who want to
do start their own startup work on very
specific challenges which has a specific
need in the market so company has a
revenue model and all those challenges
how to start a company in this space so
we started this by working on this
microbiome in health and wellness which
I think many of you have heard about so
in this hackathon what we are doing is
that we are working on the need of uh
healthcare industry by working on skin
and beauty products obesity and
Precision Nutrition pregnancy and
femtech in many of these I have a direct
application into the market into the
industry into the healthcare industry
which is uh which I think many of you
are aware of and we have been discussing
it about a lot so I'll not go into the
detail of how this technology is helping
in is these fields but to tell you a
little bit about the connections how you
get a job opportunity so we have like
co-founders CEOs entrepreneurs uh
founders of these wonderful companies uh
who are come coming along and helping
students they are also looking for
students who have this uh kind of neck
enact to be able to work on problems
understand a problem and find Solutions
and all of this could be done in a
structured way which which is what I was
showing you so these mentors are helping
in the same way you develop a connection
you you develop a relationship and then
you you start you have a connection and
that's the connection we are trying to
make well and trying to offer to those
who are joining and are participating
with us to get connected with the
industry Founders and co-founders and
find yourself the right opportunity that
you would want to have in your career to
start your career or to you know go to a
better go get a better opportunity so um
this is what in terms of a startup
business we are doing and I already told
you the job opportunities that are there
for you to take uh uh based on the skill
sets that you develop here based on the
hard skills based on the soft skills so
both of them are important and uh like
as I said like this is a training
program plus uh opportunity so it's just
not you know job opportunities we are
providing the right kind of training for
you to get those job opportunities get
to those
um ideas which are really relevant and
could have a business model so this is
what we have been doing in the hackathon
which is focused on on you know Finding
solutions to a pressing challenges in
this field of you know skin microbiome
gut microbiome vaginal microbiome and
its application in Industry uh and what
what all the things that are required we
have those infrastructure which is which
is really helpful in developing a
product so how do you develop a product
so from you know training to job to
product all of these opportunities are
there in omics logic and if you're
interested you can start your journey
today by joining these research
fellowship program which is a great
program because uh in three months to
six months people and students have
shown that we they can with the help of
team with the help of the server with
the help of the codes with the help of
the courses publish really meaningful
research in a very short term in a very
short term and get the right kind of
opportunities but because an
international publication is really a
good validation of what you have learned
so we have several uh students who have
been able to achieve this in different
types of areas of research so Ruth we
published Neuroscience supanta worked on
infectious diseases and we you can work
on many other areas as as that are there
available so some of the guaranteed
outcomes is uh if you if you're not
looking for a publication but you're at
a beginner level and slowly wants to
develop this you have limited time so
understanding the challenges associated
with bioinformatics and where these
Technologies are applied so a basic
training will give you those
understanding and it's really something
that you could do at your free time
using our basic subscription model which
we'll be discussing in a while and then
we have this training and skill
development which are very relevant to
the certification that you will be
getting to the job opportunities that
are available in the industry because
the keywords that you're learning and
that the company are posting uh those
are similar so you're learning these
keywords and you're seeing those
keywords being asked by the company and
the recruiters who would want to offer
you a job opportunity you have to apply
you have to give an interview you have
to Showcase what you have learned you
have to maybe show your project a
publication is going to help a lot so
working on a project and then completing
that project is very important and there
are several outcomes that one could get
after completing that entire process so
um there is an opportunity about that
and that's why we are meeting here today
uh to join the uh almost logic winter
research fellowship program which is
open for all uh now and uh to know about
these internships and fellowship and how
you can help you know go to the next
level we have some commonly asked
questions which we'll be answering so
can this program for the requirement for
a universe City internship what is the
difference between three months and six
month program how many hours commitment
does a research Fellowship require
mentorship options topics participation
and pricing payments and scholarships so
all of this uh to get answers to all of
these questions I'd like to invite uh
sparsh here
to help students and go through the uh
go through those topics which are really
relevant for you to get on board
um thank you again let me see the
questions and get uh to the answers one
by one
uh yes sir so uh there's a very first
question from ABE Singh and he's asking
I have done my MSC in physics and is
there any project related to Mike field
and his field of interest is
radiological physics
uh okay a bad thing you're talking about
our best thing
yes sir it's the very first query that
we have in the chat
uh radiological physics uh so what is
the question
he has done his MSC in physics and he's
asking is there any project related to
my field and his research interest is in
radiological physics
all right I I don't think we have
anything on radiological physics so far
um as a project but we can work on any
project that the research fellows are
proposing which are relevant to
biological data so if there is a
research proposal and and that's how
research projects work is that you go
through the basic training you
understand what are the tools available
and then apply it for the research
problem that you are thinking about so
if you're thinking about radiological
physics you can start looking at what
data is available and then we can go
about it to design a project but that is
to work on work on a project but for
that you have to go through some of the
basic things that we have just covered
in this session some some of the
technologies that we are offering you
for you to learn to be able to apply
those in your own field in Radiology in
radiological physics and the data that
you get from experiments in radiological
radiological physics
thank you so much sir I hope your query
got answered if you have any more
queries please share them in the chat
and another query from saksham Bhatia
hello sir I'm from computer science
background what domain should I select
for research project
okay so your computer science background
uh we are using a lot of computer
science in bioinformatics and data
science so computer science is playing a
key role when we are talking about
developing specific types of
projects when we are thinking about
specific types of algorithms by changing
some of the things that are already
available and improving an algorithm or
to even design a new tool or to start
working on a cloud tool so there are
several things that a computer science
student can contribute in in this field
of biology by informatics data science
biomedical data science so you start uh
I would recommend you to start with the
basic coursework that we offer on omis
logic you would learn about the
different things that might interest you
the most and then any computer science
student will be able to work on a
specific problem
which would be which would require
development of you know
a visual a tool or app which is what we
are doing in the hackathon where a
computer science student is working with
the biology student is working with a
business student to develop a business
idea so the computer science student is
developing an app and you know the logic
the computational model so there are
several opportunities
thank you sir and we have another query
From Grace she has her Bachelor's in
biomedical science and her interest is
in data analysis and cancer biology what
suggestions do you have sir
okay is the uh so this is who
uh Grace
okay hi Grace
so cancer biology is set
so can I get the question and see the
question
let me paste in the chat yeah because
I'm also getting some direct messages so
I'm just just reading those
uh BSC in biomedical science and I have
interest in data analysis and cancer
biology so I think we saw a great uh
great
um example of that so BSC in biomedical
Sciences so biomedical Sciences uh you
have a good foundation and you have a
good foundation in data in cancer
biology what you want to learn is data
analysis so data analysis Big Data
analysis uh omics data analysis Next
Generation sequencing all clinical data
analysis this is something that you can
learn from the portal that's what we are
offering in the uh in the research
fellowship program so you can join this
program and you can work on a specific
problem
thank you sir and then we have a query
from Ahmed uh how can I contact you I
need help with regard to data analysis
yeah you can reach out to us uh email us
um and uh our team will share the
details with me at marketing at the rate
omicslogic.com and you can also mail me
at Mohit the redpine.bio
thank you so much sir and um we have a
query from vajiha is there any
scholarship for Indian students for
undergraduates in bioinformatics
yes there are there are 20 to 50
scholarships available with this program
if you are from a low income country we
have specific
scholarships if you have a family
background and you have problems in
generating fund we give few additional
scholarship we want you to complete the
program and we would try to offer the
best that we could
please write us an email about uh about
that specifying your uh place and
location your University and all of the
detail and we'll be able to share with
you the scholarship which is available
for you
thank you sir and then Grace is asking
another query how about people who are
not from India how do we go about
interning
yeah I mean this is what we are doing so
we are not just India specific we are
working in Africa we have a team in
Africa in Nigeria in Ghana uh and also
local mentors is there so the local
mentors are helping students who are
kind of looking for specific uh hand
holding and more time but we have also
have international mentors so we are
meeting online all the time uh at USD
time at CST time for the US audience IST
time for Indian audience and GMT time
for our students and participants from
Africa so we have an international team
and an international set of mentors who
are available online to help you out uh
via the call such as zoom and everything
is recorded online so in omisologic
Portal all of your coursework all of
your progress is recorded online and and
so also in Tiba and for platform when
you run your analysis you will have of
all your pipelines all your data
analysis available on the website on the
on the web server and also in the portal
so it's really easy for the mentor to
help you because the infrastructure is
online and both of you can do solve
problems together in that scenario
thank you sir and rest of the queries
have been answered by sparsh and if you
have any personal uh queries that you
have in your chat box you can answer
them as well
okay I have some uh DMS so let me look
at those shrigori so Dr Sonia
um hi she's saying I am a PhD in
biotechnology I'm an assistant professor
and would want to join and collaborate
so um thank you Dr Sonia for reaching
out uh I'll share with you uh an email
and then we can talk more about
collaboration that how we can work
together
so let me now invite sparsh
um to uh
talk about
the the
different models that we have and how
you can join a program
thank you so much so for explaining such
like so comprehensively and extensively
about the job opportunities how they can
gain skill set and how they can bridge
the gap between industry and Academia
so I'll I'll share my screen and I'll
quickly walk you all through
the landing page that is the research
fellowship program page how one can join
this program what are the different
resources one would have access to what
are the potential outcomes of this
particular program what all uh key
points you need to remember while you
are pursuing or while you are developing
your independent research project and
then the different models we have for
this research fellowship program so This
research fellowship program as SRI gauri
explained you that this program is not
just for the students who are either
into their masters or into their uh
undergraduate like completing their
dissertation or the major This research
fellowship program is for a high
schooler also for undergrad for a
postgrad or a researcher who wants to
research and develop a independent
research project or
find something novel
so uh in this research fellowship
program you will be using some
bioinformatics resources for analysis of
complex life science data and become
worse in bioinformatics
so here we will be using we'll be
covering training we'll be covering
mentorship we will be covering T bioinfo
server
especially it looks like you're on mute
suddenly yeah I'm so sorry actually uh
today my computer is behaving a little
bit weird so so far uh so sorry so yeah
in this research fellowship program we
will be providing you with training with
mentorship and providing you with the
access of omics logic loan portal and
the t-bio info server so the omics logic
learn portal will be helping you to
learn to gain insights regarding
different domains different multi-omics
feel like genomics transcriptomic
metagenomics according to the research
according to your research interest and
then if we talk about DeBary info server
so it would be used for analysis part
for a data interpretation part for
statistical interpretation of biological
interpretation part
now um in a very Layman language we have
divided I'll explain you that we have
divided this particular program in three
stages so the first stage is about
learning the second stage is about the
analysis and the third stage is about
the manuscript writing in the first
stage you will go through with uh
different courses with different lessons
through via our omix logic learn portal
according to your research question
according to your research interest
then once your first stage is over
you'll jump on to the second state that
is your analysis stage and in your
analysis stage you'll go through with
reviewing literature that's the most
important thing after the literature
review you'll fix a data set on which
you'll be working on then after fixing
the data set you will uh work on your
methodology and after the methodology
you will come up with the results and
the statistical and the biological
interpretation of the results so this
whole thing comes under the second stage
and the third stage is whatever you have
done in your second stage and your first
you need to jot it down in a proper
scientific manner in your report in your
manuscript
so as you can see here we are covering
different topics so the first topic is
Introduction to bioinformatics where
we'll be providing you with the insights
and Glimpse and understanding of what is
bioinformatics how bioinformatics is
used in healthcare how bioinformatics is
being used in translational research and
then the basics of data in life sciences
we will be covering omics data types
like genomics transcriptomics or
metagenomics third we'll be covering
data science and machine learning for
non-engineers as I could see that there
are some students who are from Computer
Sciences background or so we are
covering we are we are having subjects
like artificial intelligence deep
learning machine learning supervised
unsupervised so we are covering these
subjects also and then R and Python
programming language and in-depth
analytics for complex or mixed data so
these are the topics which one can
learn and leverage from other than these
topics we are also working on some
specialization tracks like infectious
diseases like neurosciences like
Precision oncology Precision medicines
Agriculture and bioinformatics Etc
second point that what particular things
you should remember while you are in
your research Fellowship tenure and you
are completing and developing a research
project first is make sure that your
research question is compelling
those who are already into the field and
those who are already working on
something uh finding on something
finding new second is such specific
parameters to answer the research
question conclusively find a data set
that fit your objective and explore them
for batch effects advice and the fourth
is get feedback from our expert mentors
on your topic and Analysis proposal so
if any at any given point of time if you
feel stuck and you want a guidance so
our Mentor our expert our industry
Academia expert mentors will be there to
guide you on each step from your
training phase to analysis phase and
then the manuscript writing phase so
there are some potential outcomes of
This research fellowship program that is
expert feedback and overall evaluation
of project quality Innovation and
Analysis execution second is after your
research project is completed you have
an opportunity to present your poster to
make a poster and present it in our
research Symposium which happens by a
new
third is path to collaboration with
expert mentors or faculty at partner
universities or across Globe from
different Industries or from academic
institutions and for this path to a full
publication so one can also publish
their work in a peer-reviewed journal
and as we have showed some examples also
so now so this is a link
please join this particular link so as
to stay updated please join this
particular group so as to stay updated
about our different webinars which we'll
be conducting from uh for research
fellowship program and uh the different
webinars for different topics and
domains so now uh if I move further so
we have three different models one is of
45 days then is of 60 days and then is
of 90 days so the resources which we'll
be providing you in all three tenures is
asynchronous courses Hands-On
assignments group sessions program
course access omics logic program access
educational Cloud pipelines online
Mentor Support Online technical support
group Live sessions Etc so the
difference comes in the outcome if
you'll enroll for 45 days the outcome is
literature review and project report if
for 60 the outcome is literature review
project report and research poster if
for a 90 the outcome is literature
review project report and a research
paper publication
further you can see here there are like
there are registration links for this uh
this program if someone is interested
and want to uh
like enroll and be the part of research
fellowship program they can simply visit
on this particular link according to
their interest for how many tenure they
wanted to join and do their research
project and
they can simply click and they can
process proceed further with the payment
check out now here you can see that how
our research fellows have completed
their research project on different
domains like infectious diseases space
or mixed research precision and college
research machine learning and modeling
skin disease data-driven drug Discovery
and so on so these are just few examples
so we have more than 32 or 34 example
research projects on our own mix logic
loan portal maybe she probably can share
the link and you can explore more
am I visiting there so beta mentors we
have industry and academic mentors both
so Professor Palo redana from Faba Dr
harpreet Kaur Dr Mohit mazumda Dr
raghavendra and Dr asona vasudeva and
many more so here are some students blog
and they have shared their experience
they have shared their what kind of
research they have done in these
particular blocks do visit and get a
glimpse how to develop your own project
so this is this was all about the uh
registration uh the resources the
different models or you can sign up you
can register and you can get started
with developing your own research
project so if anyone is having any query
regarding the registration part please
feel free to bring in the chat box and
I'll be there to answer your queries
thank you
over to you sugary
thank you so much Parish so I guess we
will pause for a couple of uh minutes so
that if anyone has any queries they can
share it in the chat and I've also
shared the contact number and the email
ID of sparsh so that if the participants
are having any queries at any point of
time you can reach out to her and the
contact number is also active on
WhatsApp so you can next time
so with that I'll just pause for a
couple of minutes and otherwise I'll end
the meeting
uh you could also feel free to unmute
yourself and ask your queries and we
will be happy to guide you
I guess there are no more queries should
worry we are good to go all right then
thank you so much thank you to all the
participants for joining today's web and
with that I hope to see you all for the
research fellowship program as well and
with that thank you everyone and have a
great day